c'est un des hôtels les plus connus du
monde et pourtant il n'existe sortir
la chanson hotel california lancé en
1977 figures dont plusieurs listes des
meilleures chansons de tous les temps
elle fait partie d'un album concept du
même titre qui est une critique du monde
musical et de l'ebit de rockstar la
chanson hotel california c'est un peu le
piège de la quête du succès la quête du
rêve américain
les gens sont prêts à faire n'importe
quoi pour devenir des vedettes
[Musique]
c'est une chanson qui parle de
l'amérique des années soixante dix
mais d'une façon plus plus sombre fait
référence à la décadence des états unis
et l'égoïsme l'égocentrisme au coeur de
la chanson une mystérieuse femme qui
accueille le visiteur à l'hôtel
california ce qu'on sait c'est que john
frei en déco compositeur de la chanson
un des membres des ieg 11 s'est inspiré
d'une rupture amoureuse et maniement
chagrin d'amour alors cette femme-là
représente aussi cette cette femme qu'il
a aimée faiblit c'est une femme qui le
fait souffrir
une histoire personnelle qui trouve avec
cette chanson une résonance universelle
des egos dans les années 70 ce site est
une machine c'est des rock stars
la machine max tard le monstre black
stars c'étaient les eagles y avait des
jeunes comme d'albums qui avait été
lancée mais là ils sont devenus comme
des méga stars de la musique sur 2000
plus des icônes cdn fielder qui
composent la première version
instrumentale
quand on dit que c'était une des grandes
chansons d'été c'est peut-être normal
parce que quand celui que développer
l'intro à la guitare acoustique
le fait est distant en plein coeur du
mois de juillet certaines bâtisses lgt
en maillot de bain de tout mouillé j'ai
pris ma guitare j'ai commencé à m'amuser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les éléments étaient réunis pour
coter le california connaissent un
triomphe et deviennent classé site une
excellente chanson c'est le refrain et
par accrocheur et la musique et le
fameux solo de guitare incroyable
[Musique]
une chanson qui inspire et qui a été
reprise de nombreuses fois à la sauce
flamenco par les big sea king
[Musique]
interprété par isabelle boulay
l'uci
ou en version web et par le groupe muñoz
[Musique]
en 1994 legal eux mêmes ont repris la
chanson en version acoustique lui
donnant un nouvel élan
on voit que cette chanson là à quelque
chose d'intemporel qui marque à la fois
son époque mais qui qu'on souhaite
entendre encore c'est elle est
intemporelle dans le sens où elle voyage
avec nous
[Musique]
potel californie à une adresse
imaginaire qui quarante ans plus tard
continue d'attirer les rêveurs ici mais
bien alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]